Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
en español Soy Jorge Hurtado hoy
hablaremos sobre cómo la tecnología está
cambiando los empleos en América Latina
los desafíos que trae la automatización
Y cómo los trabajadores pueden
prepararse para estos cambios para esto
conversaremos con Freddy Vega cofundador
y ceo de platzzi una de las plataformas
de Educación profesional en línea más
importantes de la región Freddy
bienvenido cómo estás Hola Muchísimas
gracias por invitarme bueno Freddy la
primera pregunta cómo la tecnología en
realidad está transformando el mercado
laboral en América Latina En qué
industrias específicamente o sectores
ese cambio ya es tangible
la realidad es que el software se comía
el mundo hay dos tipos de empresas las
empresas que están implementando
software en su núcleo en suma de negocio
y las empresas que inevitablemente se
van a morir suena muy duro y en
ocasiones Son increíbles las personas
van a decir pero yo tengo una empresa
que hace salsa picante A mí que me
importa el software Pero la realidad es
que el software está adquiriendo todas
las diferentes aristas y todas las
verticales de nuestra economía para que
tengas una idea Colombia el país donde
originalmente soy en el
2014-2015 menos del 2% de la exportación
de servicios era servicios de
tecnologías de las comunicaciones y la
información Hoy es el 7%. Esto está
pasando en toda la región Porque nuestro
verdadero recurso renovable más valioso
es la mente humana de la gente que está
en nuestras naciones y cada vez más una
computadora conectada a internet es un
igualador de cultura lo que hace que
todos los modelos de negocio tengan
software y que aquellos que no
eventualmente sean aniquilados y
absorbidos por los modelos que sí Freddy
pero algunos sindicatos y organizaciones
los derechos laborales son críticos
precisamente a estos cambios según ellos
la tecnología también es vista como una
amenaza para algunos trabajos sobre todo
en aquel áreas donde esos trabajos
pueden ser reemplazados por máquinas o
pueden ser automatizados es resistencia
esto al cambio o es una realidad
es curioso porque yo creo que había como
una una teoría muy muy fuerte de que la
gran mayoría de los trabajos que iban
inicialmente ser reemplazados por
máquinas quieren hacer los trabajos
repetitivos los trabajos de camioneros
conductores
operadores de cosas como los típicos
trabajos repetitivos por lo que resulta
que está pasando con la innovación de
Inteligencia artificial en los últimos
años es que los primeros empleos que
están siendo absorbidos son los empleos
de entrada el primer empleo que tiene un
abogado hoy en día hay una Inteligencia
artificial que se llama gpt3 que es
capaz de analizar como si fuera un
humano grandes cantidades de información
similar a lo que hacen los paralelas los
asistentes legales los primeros trabajos
de contadores los primeros trabajos de
diseño de press gráficos con
inteligencia artificiales como tal y
como stable difusion y así estamos
encontrando hace poco viene Inteligencia
artificial que le tomas una foto a tu
cocina y automáticamente te produce 100
200 variaciones de aprendiendo de otras
cosinas como lo que normalmente quería
enseñar de interiores es impresionante
claramente no reemplaza a los mejores de
la industria claramente no va a
reemplazar las personas top de cada
disciplina pero si va a ser que los
primeros empleos sean más complicados
las soluciones simple y es muy similar
al inicio es aprender de software es
aprender a que la tecnología no sea un
impedimento para que nuestras carreras
crezcan sino que son herramientas que
aceleren nuestras carreras pero sin duda
Va a requerir un cambio mentalidad
porque lo que creíamos de que iba a
reemplazar los empleados operativos y
repetitivos no lo que va a reemplazar es
los empleos interesantes creativos Pero
de entrada
Por otra parte Freddy del banco
interamericano de desarrollo y son
estudios donde muestran cómo los empleos
que más crecen en América Latina y el
Caribe están relacionados precisamente a
la economía digital te pregunto qué
ocupaciones en tecnología han crecido
más y cuáles podrían desaparecer en el
futuro
casi todas las ocupaciones relacionadas
con tecnología empezaba a crecer hay un
dato muy chistoso que hace poco leía las
habilidades blandas pues las células
blandas es algo que todos los empleados
quieren y casi siempre lo que quieran
decir con habilidades blandas es como no
pues que lleguen a tiempo que hablen
bien que sean respetuosos Pero recuerdo
un estudio creo que en Singapur que
trató de definir habilidad blanda
habilidad blanda como habilidades
comunes para todo tipo de empleo y la
habilidad más común blanda para todo el
tipo de empleo resultó ser Excel Excel
es tan fundamental y lo mismo está
pasando con otros elementos tecnológicos
que vemos Nosotros desde plástico
nuestros estudiantes que la demanda es
altísima para desarrollo de software
para seguir informática para diseño
interactivo no tanto para diseño gráfico
el diseño gráfico no tiene una vuelta
demanda pero el diseño de interfaces el
diseño de aplicaciones móviles tiene una
demanda ridícula el marketing digital
pero por ejemplo no tanto el marketing
tradicional Obviamente el marketing
digital digital requiere habilidades de
marketing tradicional pero por sí solo
no tanta demanda Y luego están las
intersecciones lo que nosotros vemos una
y una y otra vez con los estudiantes de
plata Espero que tienen los crecimientos
de salario más grandes después de un año
los que incrementen su salario de 300
dólares al mes a 3000 dólares al mes o
más tienden a ser los que tienen una
intersección de conocimientos hablan
inglés el solo hecho hablar inglés
aumenta un 48% tu salario en promedio en
la industria tienen habilidades blandas
de gestión de talento creativo Y
probablemente combinan ciencias de datos
con una carrera tradicional o
programación con marketing o marketing
con diseño ese nunca parar de aprender Y
ese cambio de mentalidad lo que
realmente sea la diferencia Freddy pero
pese a esta demanda del talento que
existe en la tecnología existe también
un déficit en la región la consultora
page Group dice que a finales del 2022
más o menos habrá un déficit del 48% de
mano de obra digital en América Latina
Cómo se podría superar esta demanda Y si
existen te pregunto políticas públicas
en la región destinadas para esto
es mi trabajo Eso es lo que nosotros
hacemos en clase nosotros hacemos
nuestro mejor esfuerzo por formar a la
próxima generación de profesionales
emprendedores y empleados y tecnología
en el mundo si hay muchos iniciativas de
políticas públicas pero es bien
complicado porque las iniciativas de
políticas públicas no siguen las
políticas de contratación y empleo
también un ejemplo en Latinoamérica por
ejemplo Colombia tienen el Ministerio de
tecnología una iniciativa muy fuerte de
entregar a través de claxy becas para
que personas que necesitan aprender
tecnología desde cero lo puedan hacer
Pero por otro lado los gobiernos siguen
exigiendo títulos yo creo que ese es el
problema más grande en Latinoamérica en
carreras formales de tecnologías se
gradúan más o menos 100.000 personas al
año cuando incluyes incluso los buscan
de innovadores pero la demanda es de un
millón y esa demanda continúa creciendo
esa es la razón por la que en esta
industria el desempleo no existe y las y
Los sueldos son tan altos son techo
altísimos es como ridículo ver una
persona que se demoró un año y medio
aprendiendo ganando más que un recién
grabado de Medicina pero aunque sea
ridículo es la realidad del mercado y es
la demanda que existe por otro lado sin
embargo tenemos este tema en el contrato
social latinoamericano donde no
consideramos algo que no sea un título
como algo formal que realmente es
educación todavía creemos que la
educación es algo que tiene un inicio y
un fin y que nuestra personalidad la
Define una decisión que tomamos Cuando
tenemos 17 18 años que nos tocó estudiar
cinco años en un lugar y entonces lo que
vamos a hacer toda la vida Eso no es
verdad yo conozco abogados que se
volvieron científicos de datos yo he
visto enfermeras que de repente están en
el flujo de calidad y las pruebas de
software yo he visto personas que al
combinar tecnología o incluso
simplemente habilidades de la economía
digital No solamente la tecnología
aumenta en sus carreras y que tienen
tres cuatro cinco diferentes posiciones
en sus vidas con una vida muy
interesante y divertida eso va a
requerir que cambiemos el contrato
cultural y la la importancia de que un
título es suficiente está bien ir a la
universidad las universidades son súper
importantes es la forma en la que
nosotros creamos nuevo conocimiento lo
que está mal es creer que eso es
suficiente para triunfar en un mundo que
están aceleración constante quedarte
quieto o seguir el camino lineal que te
dejaron tus papás es lo mismo escuchar
para atrás por eso que empezar a tener
una cultura radical y agresiva de nunca
parar de aprender Y a propósito de los
estudiantes de Black se ha visto
muchísimos testimonios positivos de
personas que tras estudiar tecnología
consiguen un buen empleo y mejora su
salario como mencionabas pero este
cambio en la demanda laboral estaría
provocando una especie de entre comillas
desplazados tecnológicos o sea personas
que pierden su empleo por trabajos
automatizados o porque no se adaptaron a
esta nueva demanda tecnológica así como
una brecha salarial qué pasaría con ello
esto es verdad Pero la realidad es que
yo estaba como leyendo mucho de lo que
ha pasado en otras en otras revoluciones
tecnológicas por ejemplo Qué pasó en la
época en la que cambiaron de carruajes
con caballos a automóviles que pasó en
la época en la que cambiamos de
operadoras telefónicas a que la central
telefónica operario automáticamente y lo
que he encontrado Es que esto en general
es como un punto político que no que no
es verdad no es verdad que la gente dijo
que como Bueno pues me queda desempleado
y pues me tocó sufrir en la casa La
verdad es que las personas son
inteligentes y creo que no les damos el
suficiente crédito las personas Son muy
inteligentes y hacen algo al respecto lo
que termina pasando Es que los empleos
esto es otra cosa que la gente cree que
es incorrecta la gente cree que la
economía es un país que tiene un tamaño
fijo Entonces cuando una persona obtiene
un empleo otra persona no lo tiene
cuando alguien gana es porque alguien en
otro lado perdió pero no es verdad en
silicon Valley nunca ha habido tanto
crecimiento de empresas tecnológicas
tanta inyección como ahora y en
Latinoamérica es lo mismo en el 2014 se
invirtieron en capital de riesgo para
tecnología como 500 millones de dólares
nada para una región de 650 millones de
personas el año pasado en el 2021 que el
año pasado fue como uno de esos sueños
de fiebre de inversión que así es como
medio raro pero se invirtieron casi 16
mil millones de dólares múltiples
órdenes de magnitud más de lo que se
invertía antes lo que pasa no es que un
empleo mata otro empleo lo que pasa es
que los empleos crecen lo que pasa es
que más gente obtiene cosas nuevas
cuando los carruajes desaparecieron
aparecieron los taxis cuando
desaparecían las centrales telefónicas
desaparecieron los call centers cuando
una industria crece todos crecemos y en
particular la industria la tecnología es
especial porque hace un uso muy pequeño
de recursos naturales el único recurso
que nosotros usamos es una computadora
conectada a internet que es
relativamente bajo Comparado con otras
industrias y que hace que sea nuestro
talento nuestra creatividad nuestra
mente lo que se vuelva a nuestra
capacidad productiva entonces lo que
termina pasando Es que se crean no
solamente más empleos sino que los
terminan siendo de mejor calidad sin
embargo si hay un periodo de transición
y en ese período de transición va a
haber mucha ansiedad porque el empleo no
va a ser estable y eso en una región tan
desigual como latinoamérica si puede
causar mucha angustia la buena noticia
es que las personas que primero elijan
aprender y prepararse sin importar su
edad y esto es muy importante reiterarlo
sin importar su edad van a triunfar
Freddy Muchísimas gracias por tu
participación y te esperamos en una
próxima creación aquí en France 24 a
ustedes si quieren otro punto de vista
quédense con nosotros
[Música]